à peine une once d'éclaircies brille au
dessus de peugeot japy l'activité et
saufs depuis la validation ce mercredi
par le tribunal de commerce de paris de
la reprise de l'entreprise par le groupe
f de j une bonne nouvelle
ternie par un plan social 90 des 236
salariés s'apprêtent à être licenciés
c'est un soulagement mais ce soulagement
en demi teinte
parce que effectivement c'est l'offre la
mieux-disante qui a été retenu mais il
va quand même y avoir 90 licenciements
on a 90 collègues qui vont perdre leur
travail et ça franchement c'est un gros
coup de massue
l'annnonce de ses 90 licenciements
résonne dans tout valentigney dans une
ville où l'activité commerçante est déjà
sinistré
ce plan social est un nouveau coup dur
dans cette librairie du centre ville
cliente est gérante affichent leur
soutien pour les salariés toutes les
entreprises qui ferment qui licencient
moi je trouve ces astronomique ça puis
ça s'est pas terminée tant d jusqu'à la
fin de l'année début de l'année
prochaine et la libraire craint des
répercussions sur sa propre activité
sont des personnes dont je vois les
enfants dont je vois les la famille
entière qui passe régulièrement à la
bibliothèque qui viennent au moment des
fêtes qui sont aidées souvent par leur
comité social pour acheter des livres
et oui c'est une très mauvaise nouvelle
au niveau général pertes au niveau de
petits commerces
un peu plus loin cette fromagerie assure
pouvoir compter sur des clients fidèles
mais une fois encore l'ambiance est
morose il ya déjà d'autres entreprises
qui ont fermé a déjà avant il y avait
peu jaune à lantigné quand on voit ce
qui reste c'est sûr alors après c'est
vraiment un jour ça doit fermer voilà
oui ça fait un pincement à quoi
forcément parce qu'avant c'était quand
même un bassin il y avait beaucoup
d'emplois et puis maintenant sa summer
est de plus en plus de leur côté les 90
salariés concernés ne devraient pas
tarder à recevoir leur lettre de
licenciement
il devrait quitter japy au plus tard
d'ici le 22 octobre prochain